c'est une première depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale la fête des loges qui
devait se dérouler du 26 juin au 16 août
n'aura pas lieu
le maire de la commune arnaud péricard
vient d'annoncer cette décision la
raison invoquée la crise sanitaire liée
aux kovy 19
monsieur le maire nous a expliqué les
problèmes c'était sanitaires surtout qu'
on est toujours en jaune orange et que
c'est compliqué pour organiser le flux
l'entrée des clients la distance entre
chaque client l'organisation d'un tel
événement dans la forêt de saint germain
les aurait également un impact
économique important pour la commune
le coût de l'organisation est supporté
par la commune la perte pourrait
atteindre 700 mille euros cette année en
raison d'un format réduit sur la durée
comme sur le nombre de forains présents
de leur côté les fora accuse le coup
déjà frappé par l'annulation de la foire
du trône les propriétaires l'attraction
et les restaurateurs craignent la
banqueroute avec le report de cette 360
huitième édition
la plupart qu'on l'a pas de revenus on
n'a rien du tout parce qu'on l'a l'aide
de l'état mais elle a beaucoup qui ne
touche pas c'est compliqué il faut faire
des demandes et aux et puis il ya des
plus gros fonds a qui vont au crédit ils
vont déposer le bilan
on sait pas comment ça va faire l'avenir
les organisateurs espèrent un retour à
la normale en 2021 chaque année la fête
des loges accueille près de 3 millions
de visiteurs et 200 attractions